hallo leute ich bin hier bei pixum de
wir haben hier so eine art talkshow und
wir können wir jetzt fragen stört lasst
mich jetzt sicher okay also nun stellte
fragen wir sind hier nicht auf dem
bahnhof im wartesaal ja fragt mich ich
habe euch eine menge zu erzählen ihr
werdet staunen und kommentiert mensch
kommt aus dem quark und wenn ich eure
schuld verpasst
ich bin doch euer und der gabriele ja
der den ihr kind doch muss verschiedenen
fernsehsendungen der der manchmal so ein
bisschen ihr wisst doch schon dieser
gute gabe die mögen mich und die anderen
mögen nicht erst recht ihr könnt mich
alles fragen ich habe auf alles eine
antwort und wissen auch warum ich bin
immer noch 15 ich trage zwar kleine
pampers mehr ich bin von vielen kerner
15 ich weiß damals als ich so ein junger
bengel war ich wusste nicht wo rechts
und links war das weiß ich heute und ich
bin hier drei klicks um de fragt mich
ich warte